so it's like the craziest house party
you guys have been to okay
i've got like i've got like two and they
were both in university
because of course they were yeah of
course they were do you have one i mean
i can only really think of like
if i have one if you want me to go first
there's a lot of like poop stories but
i'm like yeah this is where the poop
stories are
all my poop stories come from house
parties what who's
what like uh okay so in australia oh my
god
now i think about this was [ __ ]
disgusting but oh no no
but uh do you know what a shoei is
that's why you do the
the beer out of the shoe yeah so it's
this thing that's very typical in
australia because there's nothing
why is this typical in australia typical
house parties
the local cuisine the shui but
essentially what it is
is you it's kind of like shotgunning in
america right where
shotgunning is like you know if
someone's holding a can of beer they're
like oh shotgun it so you poke a hole on
the side and then you kind of drink it
the whole thing like this chewy is that
but way grosser you
you say hey do a shoei and then you go
around the tradition is you go around
and find whoever has the dirtiest
[ __ ] shoe oh
it's not just any shoe it's whoever has
the dirty shirt it's either you do your
own shoe or
you pick whoever's dirty is already
starting horribly and then you grab
their shoe
you pour the can of beer into their shoe
and then you drink the beer from their
shoe and that's
disgusting and i mean it's not that
exciting of a story but
my friend did a shoei once and he got
his friend's uh
shoe and he didn't realize until after
he finished the shoei that he had
stepped on his dog
[ __ ] so he had like a firm grasp he had
a firm grasp of it
and he finished it and he's like he
flipped it over he just saw like [ __ ]
just smeared on them and like normal
people would be like oh what the [ __ ]
but because he was already so ham and
he's just like
and everyone was like yeah this is
[ __ ] nasty
that's that's the only thing really and
then other than that it's just like a
lot of like
vomit stories you know the usual thing
here at house parties yeah
i mean yeah that was probably the
grossest but also the most hilarious
oh my god all right all right uconn
what's the i mean i've been to like a
few crazy house parties
uh i think most of the crazy house
parties i've been to has been in
brighton yeah so that's
like my hometown um there are some
parties that are just like
kind of like you know that scene from
american pie where you see that senior
like there's no way that
that exists in real life there's no way
this crazy shit's happening yeah
but yeah i've been to a few parties
where it was actually that crazy so i
remember one time
where there was this there was this
party who we'd heard from a friend who
heard from another friend who heard from
another friend no that kind of that kind
of thing that sounds like a hobby to a
horse
that there was a party happening in the
middle of this field i'm just like
there's no [ __ ] way this is true so
we had to drive into the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere
and i was like this is a scam we're
gonna we're gonna drive there
and there's just gonna be like it's just
gonna be like a drug dealer then or
something
yeah yeah this is gonna be like we're
gonna we're gonna get [ __ ] murdered
yeah
and so we drive to the middle of this
field and and
this keep in mind this is all pitch
black because it's like the middle of
the country
where we're driving to so we can see
[ __ ] and then we go there and it was
basically like a festival
somehow they had managed to because this
guy who had owned the farm
right had just had just told a few of
his mates that he was going to have a
party
right and then mate started telling
mates and then
that's always the worst yeah i don't
know how it spreads so wide
right jesus but i feel like it's because
no one else is having a party that
weekend and people were just egging
like people were just i really wanted to
go somewhere
i need to do a party and yeah somehow
there was a [ __ ] festival
and then things started getting weird
they started saying things on fire
right so so they went into
his house right and then they took out
this sofa
and somebody thought it would be a fun
idea to just start burning stuff
so it starts why is always one person
there's always one pirate
one [ __ ] pyromaniac right and so
first it starts with a chair so they get
a chair out right i'm like okay let's
set this on fire
and it's like it's like [ __ ] caveman
mode activates
like whenever whenever you start to fire
for some reason
like you see fire so then you're like oh
fire
and then like you start [ __ ] dancing
around like oh
fire i don't know why whenever there's a
fire in there like a house party and
there's alcohol involved
you just forget the lizard brain just
takes over and you just
you just like circling just watch it
yeah and then so they burn they burn the
chair down and they're like
what can we do next what can we do next
next let's get a table
so so out of nowhere just take this
guy's whole [ __ ] ikea collection
like jesus so then they take a table
they set that on fire then as that's on
fire a [ __ ]
sofa appears out of nowhere and then
they [ __ ] just
chuck the sofa in oh my gosh and then we
were just like
at the back of my mind i'm thinking man
the host must feel so [ __ ]
[ __ ] like i don't know where he's
probably plastered out his mind
and then as the sofa is on fire we
actually see the host
just walk out and he just looks at this
so his sofa and like his [ __ ] ikea
furniture collection that's on fire and
just goes
yeah what if right what if
all along you planned this out right
because in the uk if you want to get rid
of stuff like that you've got to pay a
lot
yeah so maybe this was all a ploy just
so he could get new sofas and shares and
not pay to remove his old ones
yeah there's always also that one guy in
any kind of situation like that where
something's put on fire where they're
like holding a alcoholic beverage and
they're like i wonder what happens if i
pour it off
like this will probably put it out right
it just makes the flame bigger it's like
oh
i wasn't expecting that okay every time
every [ __ ] time animals yeah [ __ ]
cavemen
there was uh so you know how i said i
lived in like a student village yeah
yeah it was basically a whole area that
was just houses and they had
also two really big uh like apartment
blocks and they were disgusting they
were like the cheapest apartment blocks
you could imagine
and uh one time people this doesn't
exist anymore this place they tore it
all down
so yeah swansea student village r.i.p um
they said like
oh yeah there's gonna be a party at one
of the apartment buildings they didn't
say which floor or anything so i thought
that was kind of weird
yeah and then we turn up and like half
of this apartment building there's like
bin bags
on all the windows right and stuff and
then you start going into this building
and it's like been turned into like the
set of the raid
like there's just [ __ ] everywhere like
there's mattresses on the floor and [ __ ]
like
all over the place and some of the rooms
are open and have like nothing left in
them and i'm like
what the [ __ ] meanwhile everyone is like
drunk as [ __ ]
there's like people doing drugs in
certain places yeah people in the
kitchen there's always that one guys in
the kitchen making food for some reason
like this building is literally like
falling apart and one guy stealing i
want a pizza pocket yeah
any beans he was just weird and it was
like
the further up you went the like more
mess it was and i remember going to one
floor
and there was just like beds all over it
and people lying down and i'm like what
the [ __ ] is going on here
that was just weird and then i just
didn't enjoy it cause i'm like what is
this wait wait wait so what was the
was like an orgy floor or like what i
didn't how did you get invited to this
party it was one of those things where
everyone in like just everyone knew it
was happening in the village apparently
so we all just turned
out the village around the village just
about this building here
and i was like i was like why did you
put uh my ass one of the guys like why
they put bin bags
on the windows and they were like oh so
they can't see what's going on inside
i'm like
who who can't see because i think
putting black
wind like blacking out all the windows
is suspicious
right yeah that's what i thought and
also a bunch of people migrating towards
this one thing
they completely [ __ ] it though i don't
know what happened to it or how this was
even possible i'm sure one of my
favorites i mean the fact that it's gone
now
yeah and then there was another party
which was really weird and it was a
house party like just a normal house
and had a bouncer which i thought was
really weird when i had a house at a
house party
and i thought it was [ __ ] loaded
right right so it was a three-story
house not that big but i thought wow
this is [ __ ] weird there's a bounce
in
the list i said my name's like you're on
the list and i'm like when did i get put
on the list
what is who's arranging this list
because my friend invited me so
he must have put me on the list and i
got inside
the first floor just is like a big
living room just has one small couch
in the corner and like a hundred people
just standing around this like
very average looking laminated like wood
floor just
people just standing around i'm like
what the [ __ ] why is there a bouncer
and then you go up the floors and it
starts to get weird yeah and of course
it doesn't if you go up floors in these
weird house parties
everybody i found out that my ass my
friend he was like oh yeah i paid the
mountain like 300 pounds just for
tonight
and i'm like why why why what would you
expect
to happen are you that worried and then
okay okay to be fair and then i realized
why he was that worried because the
second floor was just people having sex
that's actually pretty standard that's
pretty standard that's pretty standard
yeah i was like whatever and i was like
okay
i'm going to show it because the bottom
floor was just really loud i was like
maybe i want to go to the floor people
who's just chatting yeah yeah right so i
go to the third floor
and that's where it gets really [ __ ]
weird because one of the rooms is like
uh what i thought it was was like five
beds two bunk beds and instead they just
put all the mattresses on the floor
i don't know why people are doing this
yeah all the mattresses were on the
floor and like people were making out
and one of them had like uh was doing
like a needle i don't know what he was
doing and i was like oh this is weird
this is really [ __ ] weird i'm not
going here and so i was like
i asked my friend i'm like there's got
to be somewhere else we can go i do not
want to stay here there is someone doing
what i think is heroin upstairs yeah can
we can we not do this yeah yeah
university is a mess jesus christ i've
never had any like that because i hung
out with good christian boys
so do i but sometimes you go to a party
right because you hear about a party
right you don't know what it's going to
be like till you get there
yeah until you see someone doing like
hardcore drugs upstairs and you're like
i'm not supposed to be here i i don't do
that i need to go to church
with the house parties the more stays
you go up is like the closer you get to
hell
it's like the steps towards hell it's
literally the raid that's like the
opposite right
the further up you go the closer you get
to hell that's awful because i mean you
have no way of knowing in the uk what
the party's going to be like to
get there if your friend's like dead set
on going you're like all right fine
because i've been to as many like dud
parties where you go to and it's like
this isn't a party this is a house
gathering
yeah yeah with with like prettied up
we're freezing that's what we're doing
right you never know a party could mean
like
a come dine with me four people making
dinner for each other experience or it
could be
you know a [ __ ] orgy going on
upstairs yeah you don't know until you
get there
jesus christ no one knows my parents are
probably terrified they're like
what was conor doing in university i was
not doing anything mother
i was just you happened to go to places
and they [ __ ] up